August 13, 2021, marks the 60th anniversary of
the Berlin Wall. Why was it built, and what does
it say about our world today? Following World War
II, the forces that defeated the Nazis divvied up
Germany, and in 1949 East Germany was established.
Conditions were oppressive, and by July 1961,
millions of East Germans had left for West
Germany, with around 1,000 more leaving every day.
While the border between East and
West Germany was already well guarded,
passage from East Berlin to West Berlin remained
an easy loophole. To prevent further emigration,
East Germany built a wall surrounding West
Berlin. For the next 28 years, the wall ensured
that few East Germans escaped. Today, different
countries are erecting walls of a digital kind,
but such walls are not impassable, and they are
not permanent. Regimes may have the power to shut
their populations in, but East Germany's efforts
suggest they'll ultimately fail. That's a powerful
message to today's authoritarians. Is the world
freer today than it was in 1961? Let us know in
our poll, and also let us know which other topics
you'd like our scholars to explain in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.